it is time for drew's news if news
programs were sensations we'd be that
feeling you get when you pull off your
pantyhose
with me at the desk he's got legs and he
knows how to use them rossi ross
matthews
[Applause]
can we talk about your like half the
updo how cute this is i feel like you
are cheerleader and i'm about to ask you
to prom that's what i feel like
i do feel like i'm channeling a little
inner sydney sweeney like
sydney sweeney from white lotus euphoria
she's like she's going to be in the new
uh black widow cody johnson love her she
came on the show love her
well first up today in our news volks
make cover girl the stunning mom to be
rihanna that's right
when she got pregnant rihanna says that
she knew one thing
she'd never see a maternity aisle
because she loves to dress up she talks
about the father of the baby her partner
asap rocky and she says she doesn't want
guys out of the friend zone easy and
she's known him for a decade but
everything changed over the pandemic
when they took a road trip just the two
of them across the country in a tour bus
oh god she's not sure if she's having a
baby shower but if she does it'll be
co-ed with cocktails she says she wants
people to leave plastered and crawling
out yes god she is everything everything
rihanna
there's so much
there's so much to break down one i want
to go to that baby shower and get drunk
two
interesting that they were friends and
got out of the friend zone she doesn't
want to wear maternity clothes all i
want to wear is maturity clothes that
stuff looks so elastic jeans sign me up
yeah you work you make caftans thank you
very much for knowing that i do i have
one and then also who wants to go on a
road trip with rihanna now right doesn't
that sound fun
[Applause]
i feel like
do you think on a road trip she's like
shut up and
drive it's a rihanna song
we're on a road trip together i love
everything about her i do love that
she's completely flipping the script on
maternity style she shows the bump it's
skin tight it's bare she's stylish she
really like
i have to say i really loved my pregnant
stomach because it was the first time my
stomach was tight
um
i'm not kidding not even joking a little
really i should have sported it out more
and i feel like she's given all women
license to like
ditch the norms and the confines of what
we think we're supposed to dress like as
pregnant women yeah also i have intel
about the rihanna shoot that's right my
daughter's beautiful stepmother ally
works at vogue and i asked her was there
any insider information and she says
apparently the baby was kicking like
crazy through the whole shoot so when
you see the cover think of that yummy
moment how great is that thanks allie so
cute i know
ross your story all right well next up
we have a controversial new dating
concept are you ready for this uh d
marge reports the new trend is called
tryst timing tryst timing and here's how
it works people are going on dates and
beforehand they secretly set a timer on
their phone uh to set off a ringtone
exactly 37 minutes into the date so your
phone will go off it'll ring like
someone's calling you right so if the
date is a total horror show you have an
escape hatch right so you can say like
oh i'm so sorry it was my landlord and i
oh oh what oh there's a leak i have to
go
on the other hand if the date is going
well the phone can ring and you can be
like you know what i'm going to ignore
this because
i'm really feeling this right which
gives you like brownie points
is it diabolical or is it smart
oh i don't know who likes this concept
show of hands
raise them up i want to know because it
helps me
i mean i'll always be my own person at
the end of the day but i do like
decisions by committee yeah
um okay
yeah i like one half of this which one
half of your
um i'm having such a good time i'd love
to not take this call that is sweet and
i like sweet
i
although i suppose i am a professional
actor
i cannot do this i can't pull it off you
can't fake it hell no
really here's what i here's what i do
call me okay ring ring ring ring hello i
don't have anything else you need to
hold it inside okay
hello drew hello hi
hi
oh uh there's a leak you gotta leave
there's a leak
you're so bad i know oh yeah it's bad
you gotta get home right now oh my god
okay uh
uh
um
there's an emergency and i'm so sorry
and and then i'll be there for the next
10 minutes trying to explain and
apologize and i i this i can't i can't
do this i can't pull these
ruses off
[Music]